the next speaker is mr. Markham's from
the sharp animal center of the year for
the unknown and he will talk about
quality areas in the actual
communication suspects all right so
first thanks to Fritz and Terry for
organizing the workshop it's been very
interesting so it's a pleasure being
here just one thing that kind of
happened is that initially my
understanding was I was going to give a
half an hour talk and then I was very
lucky to figure out actually have one
hour time and so the question was so
I'll just stretch this talk you know
speak half as fast or introduce more
details but I think I decided maybe a
bit similar to tell it to like take a
bit more of a high level perspective and
embed it in in a bit more context and so
I'm going to talk about linear readouts
and their surprising consequences
understand that some of you are maybe
more from computer science so maybe I
should first define what I mean by a
linear readout so here's the way I were
to find a linear readout so you have a
bunch of neurons and they're spiking
okay this will be the spike trains in
the linear readout especially the
following procedure you filter the spike
trains for instance by an exponential
kernel a Gaussian kernel or whatnot a
way of barely extracting something that
I would call the instantaneous firing
rate and then you linearly combine all
these instantaneous firing rates through
a decoder or decoder matrix to basically
get linear readouts those are analog
quantities okay that's a concept that
has been used in neuroscience for
actually quite a long time I trace it
back to George opera's but you may
correct me they may have been T but
before that it you start and so the
question is why do I care and I care for
the following reason because one of the
frustrating things in systems
neuroscience is that Bayes lead always
seems everything
fair game everything can be played
around with it's not like we have a
neuron model that we can all agree on
you know people use firing red neurons
they use integrating fire neurons use
conducting space neons there's not a
connectivity that we can agree on maybe
there will be soon but we are
feed-forward networks we have recurrent
networks so you can play around with so
many things that it is a bit frustrating
but what I sort of discovered at least
in my work is that there's basically one
invariant one thing that I have been not
playing around with for 10 years not
intentionally in some sense it's rather
with hindsight that I noticed
I always keep coming back to that
concept they never has been a reason for
me to not use it and that is basically
the linear readout okay and so you'll
see it pop up in my talk so we'll talk
about three topics first I'm going to
talk about singer populations singer
populations of neurons and higher-order
areas such as the prefrontal cortex now
you can disentangle representations that
look very complex on the single cell
level essentially using linear readouts
then we're going to talk about two
populations at the same time recordings
from v1 and v2 we're trying to
understand how one population feeds into
the next population so it's about inter
area communication and then I'm going to
give a teaser just a few minutes okay
but about some work that I've been doing
with Sofie TANF which is about how
linear readouts if you combine it with
the principle of efficiency actually can
explain things such as excited to
inhibitory imbalance in networks and
robustness of neural networks in general
so let's start with the first topic
disentangle representations in higher
order areas this is work that I've
mostly done with a former postdoc in the
lab Dmitri Kovac and a graduate student
villain Grendel who are the ones that
actually in some sense
I'd say went through the math and
invented the method that we're now using
to disentangle these representations
so here's the problem that we started
out with I guess by no more than ten
years ago and it's the following you
have a recording from a monkey higher
order area it's the prefrontal cortex an
area that is in some sense is considered
an executive area where things come
together you know we're working memory
comes together standard information
comes together actions are being chosen
that's one way of thinking about it so
it's a fairly high high order area in
the brain if you give a monkey that is
doing a very simple task well the monkey
is barely doing is getting a vibratory
students frequency on its fingertip
frequency f1 then there's delay for
three seconds then it gets a second
vibratory students frequency and then it
has to decide whether f1 is larger than
f2 or not so it's a very simple working
memory task he have a single neuron from
the prefrontal cortex recorded by
renewed for Romo and that basically on
the x-axis you have time on the y-axis
you have the time varying firing rate
the instantaneous firing rate in this
case averaged over trials so it's a psdh
and the different colors represent
different stimulus frequencies f1 okay
so it goes from f1 being ten Hertz all
the way to f1 being soda four Hertz so
these four different different task
conditions and what you see is for this
neuron you know initially before the
first students frequency comes on it's
actually firing with a background rate
of 20 Hertz then these colors spread out
so this neuron now carries information
about that per student frequency f1 then
that information persists in this delay
period of three seconds within where the
monkey has to memorize has to remember
the first imminence frequency and then
afterwards we know sort trials according
to the decision that the monkey is going
to make so whether decides yes or no you
know the f1 was larger than f2 or not
and you nicely see the decision actually
arising here
the monkey is actually pressing the
button later on so this is kind of
predictive of the decision that it's
going to make and that's just a single
neuron a PFC now everything would be
very simple if all neurons in the
prefrontal cortex were like that but
unfortunately that's not the case
if you look across neurons then it
starts looking a lot more complex
so here have different types of
different neurons and you see you know
some of them don't care a lot about the
first team of frequencies I just have
some interesting dynamics some of them
do care about the first image frequency
but then there's nothing about the
decision
some of them basically have suddenly the
C related activities such as this one
here but they didn't have any short-term
memory so you know what kinds of
complexity and so this has sometimes
been termed a mixed selectivity in
single cells and it's been a great
problem for people that want to analyze
data and these higher-order areas
because what are you supposed to make of
it okay in some sense one of the first
things I did when I had this data set it
had like a thousand neurons is just
print them all out one by one and it's
not super illuminating if you do that
you sort of notice you know there are
sort of common recurring patterns but
it's not like you find two neurons that
do exactly the same thing every neuron
is a bit different so one conclusion one
could draw from this is that really
looking at single cells in some sense
must be irrelevant and we have to
understand what is going on on a higher
level on the level of the population of
neurons so if we do that then we come
back to this idea that we've already
heard of several times of neural
manifolds that may be what's happening
if you have several neurons such a
neuron one two or three the firing rates
here and you trace out the activity of
these neurons over time that these
activities you know don't lie in the
full high dimensional space of
population activities but they lie
within some kind of manifold that we may
want to characterize now in a nicely
talked about how to correct rise
manifold if you don't assume you have
any other types of information except
for the population activity but what I
want to do in some sense is ask okay can
we assign some type of meaning to such a
manifold in a more supervised door see
my supervisors way and what do I mean
with meaning so one way of thinking
about meaning is to say okay let's
assume we move around on that manifold
then we can interpret such a move on the
manifold as actually a change in a
linear readout with a linear read out
again is better
the linear combination of the firing
rates of the neurons so imagine that you
that the firing heights of the
population were to move in this
particular direction then maybe that
would correlate with a change in an
external stimulus that the animal is
basically observing you could imagine
that the firing is moving in another
direction could be a change in the
decision that the animal is making okay
so let's assume that's the picture of
how it actually works in populations of
neurons okay so that's an assumption if
that works then maybe the way you would
want to analyze the data in some sense
is with these multiple linear readouts
so you would say now I take the firing
raids of these neurons and what I have
to figure out on the right way of
reading out the information from this
population such that I can separate out
information about say the stimulus
information about the decision that an
animal may make an action information
about something else a like a reward
that the animals getting etc okay that's
what you would want to do so we set out
to barely do that but since we are
theorists we want to do a little bit
more so first goal is really just to
choose readouts that D mix these
dependencies on the task parameters so
you say okay you have these neurons and
I'm illustrating the mixed selectivity
or just by a pie chart per se it says
every neuron may have information about
a stimulus decision rewards whatever you
want and they mix the information in
different ways and what you would want
to do if you want to choose those
readouts
such that it D makes us the information
okay so that you have read out this says
oh you know this one only cares about
the stimulus this one only cares about
the decision this one only cares about
the reward etc but as a theorist that
alone does not make me happy because
really one of the reasons to analyze
data is because you just want to see
what's there
and one problem was just reading out
information is that you may lose a lot
of stuff that you don't look for okay so
the other thing that we wanted is you
want to say okay we want this readout to
also be a bottleneck in the sense that
it captures everything that is going on
in the data and I guess part of the
reason
we ended up with this it's also because
we initially came from principle
component analysis which is exactly that
you know you try to reduce the
dimensionality of your data but keep as
much as possible and then chose to also
keep this information or like choose
your components in such a way that they
D mix these different bits of
information so these were the two goals
basically D makes the information
through a bunch of linear readouts but
also make sure that the bottleneck that
we create actually captures everything
that is going on in the data set and we
call the the method D mix principle
component analysis the the version I'm
going to talk about today is the one
from 2016 that does not have an
orthogonal constraint on the on the
decoding and encoding stages and here's
a in a nutshell basically how it works
so we figure out these correct readouts
the D makes information but capture
everything that's going on so what we're
going to do is we're going to take our
single neurons and we're going to
decompose their PS DHS into these
different bits of information that we
care about and so these are single
neurons from this working memory task
that I just explained so again you have
time here there's the firing rate of the
neuron this is a singer on the psdh
the different colors correspond to the
different stimulus frequencies f1 that
the monkey got and then here dashed
where the solid corresponds to the
decision that the monkey is going to
make so what we're going to do is we
first of all just gonna take the average
of that psdh we're going to subtract
that average and then we want to average
out the stimuli and the decisions if we
average our stimuli decisions then what
we get is something that you could call
the conditioned independent part it just
keeps track of the overall time the
overall change over time of this psdh
but eliminated stimulus and decision
information now you can subtract that
1/2 and average just over the decision
so there's a binary decision but if you
average over it there will be something
that we're not called the distance
dependent part okay
can subtract that too and now you can
average over the stimulus if your
average over the stimulus then what you
get is the decision dependent part okay
and then after you subtracted all of
these there's something left and that
would be any kind of interaction between
stimulus and decision that could not be
captured in this averaging procedure
okay that's the key idea
so this decomposition of data into what
we call marginalized averages it wasn't
actually invented by us it also exists
in the manova literature we're just
going to take it as a start for another
means so we do that not just for this
particular neuron the do it for all of
the neurons okay we do it for all of the
neurons and the nice thing is that this
decomposition is unique and that you
once you have these decomposed parts you
can always reconstruct the individual
neurons and now we're going to do the
following thing we're going to say okay
we want to start with a full population
activity so that will be these neurons
here on the left-hand side and we want
to find basically a set of readouts a
decoder that takes this population
activity into a bottleneck okay which
we're going to call the d'emic stimulus
components such that with this
bottleneck you can reconstruct the
stimulus dependent part of the PSD ages
okay so these components become the
steaming stimulus components because
you're not trying to reconstruct the
full PSD age you only try to reconstruct
the stimulus dependent part that we got
from these marginalised averages and the
method by which you can find this
bottleneck is basically reduced rank
regression which is essentially linear
regression under a rank constraint so
you have multiple inputs multiple
outputs
see it as a linear regression model but
you take a rank constraint on the
regression coefficients and those rank R
on Stransky with this bottleneck and if
we do it for this particular example and
these are the Dimmick stimulus
components that you get so these would
be two components that allow you to take
the original PSD ages and from them
reconstruct only the stimulus dependent
part and then you can do that of course
for the decision dependent part for the
condition independent part for the
interaction part etc and by doing it for
all of these parts separately you get a
basis that allows you to reconstruct the
whole data okay which is what we want to
do set out to do so what does this
method give us for the monkey data so if
we apply it to the monkey data then
here's the way it looks so again this is
the somatosensory working memory task
free for your cortex what I'm showing is
here is the number of components that we
extract versus the cumulative explained
variants in black you see PCA PCA
provides them an upper bound for any
kind of linear compression and then
erect you see DMX PCEHR you see that we
don't lose a lot by choosing a slightly
different basis from PCA then what you
see here is basically how much each of
these basis components now cares about
different aspects of the task so the
gray are basically what we call the
condition independent components so the
ones that only vary with the timing of
the task the blue are the stimulus
dependent components and the red are the
decision components and what is somewhat
surprising is that in fact only 11% of
the variance has anything to do with a
stimulus indecision and a lot of the
variance has to do with something else
okay and so what does that mean let me
actually show you the components so here
are the components these are these
condition independent components and
they generally just have something to do
with the timing of the task and they're
very strong they dominate the overall
activity these are the stimulus
dependent components okay so they only
care about the stimulus and you don't
see you see very very little decision
information in these stillness dependent
components and these are the decision
dependent components and one thing that
tells you is that on the population
level you can find readouts that
completely extract the stimulus
information and separate it out from the
decision information
go on I wanted to clarify how you go
through it and look at just the stimulus
or the decision dependent parts just
something that falls out of your
analysis are you somehow constraining
the rank based on how many stealing so
you have to put in what you're going to
look for so when you construct these
marginalized averages you average of our
different task parameters you have to
say what those task parameters are
exactly that's exactly
so they I don't understand what you mean
with post-hoc so that you have the
labeling already right so because you
measured it as the experimenter you kept
track of the stimuli you kept track of
the decisions so the labels are there
now which labels you include in the
analysis that's basically up to you
it'll depend on what you record it in an
experiment
it'll also depend on the amount of data
you have you cannot just include like
too many labels but just generally to
say what this is it's I mean there are
the unsupervised methods for your babies
just look at the population activity you
just look at the manifold there could be
supervised methods we try to you know
use the population activity to fit
something such as a stimulus or
something or use the stimulus to fit the
population activity this in some sense
is a semi supervised method okay it's
it's it combines unsupervised together
with with some information about these
task parameters so it's a it's a CMI
supervised method okay so one of the
things you may wonder about is you know
why is 90% of the activity in these
condition independent components and
there's one way I like to think about it
it's not necessarily the most popular
was experimentalists
but that is the following so imagine
that in this task the population
activity in the prefrontal cortex
actually does move around in this
particular manifold but not all
movements in this manifold are
experimentally controlled in fact
experimentally controlled in this
particular experiment is Regis the
stimulus frequency of one the students
frequency f2 the decision
and that's pretty much it but it could
be that there many other things that the
monkey is doing that are just not
experimentally controlled quick friends
just be the breathing maybe the
breathing you know rhythmically varies
with the tasks people have shown that in
my experiments subjects tend to
criticize their breathing breathing with
a with a timing of a task
imagine the monkey taps his foot every
single time the first team of frequency
comes some type of superstitious
learning you know happens in rodents at
least and but you didn't monitor the
tapping of the foot okay there could be
many parameters that you're actually not
monitoring things that the monkey does
that the monkey may even think important
for solving that task okay that change
along this manifold and since they're
hidden uncontrolled they will just show
up as these conditioned independent
components okay and one thing that is
kind of interesting so I will slide here
but if you apply this method to more
sensory or more motor areas what you
actually see is that the amount of
variance that goes into the conditioning
dependent component decreases so it says
if this would tell us that we understand
these sensory in these motor areas much
better than these very executive areas
or that we can control them better let's
put it this way that we have a better
idea of how to control activity in these
areas yeah just to go back to the
previous slide should we interpret your
reader readout as working only in the
tangent space to that manifold yes well
yes so the manifold picture is just a
slide yeah
so I'm putting up a manifold and that is
a that is a bit of a separate discussion
strictly speaking since we use this type
of method it's really a subspace but I
think that good arguments become come
back to that at the end of the talk that
obviously is not a linear subspace but
it can still be a linear two seconds
that is two so the monkey if the monkey
were to ignore the task the monkey could
decide whenever that it wants to press
the left or the right button if it
doesn't aw you know then it'll only get
a reward and 50% of the trials so
waiting until the end of the of the
delay period ensures that the decision
is the correct decision for the reward
so let me maybe clarify the task so the
task is you have a first stimulus
frequency of 1 that comes in here and
then where you see the decision that's
actually when the second stimulus
frequency comes in and you have to
compare f1 with f2 and only if you
properly compare the two can you make
the right decision so the decision
occurring here basically means the
monkey is actually doing the task if the
decision was occurring earlier the
monkey would kind of ignore the task and
just decide you know a priori I'm going
to hit one of the two buttons which
would not be a good strategy if you want
to really collect as much reward as you
want so you use two examples foot
tapping and I guess breathing as
uncontrolled behaviors in an
experimental setup I guess I don't see
why you have to invoke that per se and
not just say the contingencies of that
area - for the dynamics of the tab
are necessarily set up in such a way and
that's already enough to say that there
will be condition independent dynamics
or condition independent signal that's
not part that is true so you're right
you know like there can just be there
could be other reasons to explain this
couldn't or there could be other reasons
why you would have this condition
independent dynamics and just suspicious
so if I emphasize the thing with the
breathing and the tapping of the photo
if you want attention motivation or any
kind of internal signal the kinds of I
mean I'm suspicious that some of that
activity actually has meaning that's all
so I heard in church will give a talk
just a few days ago and she has a task
nah that's a rat or a mouse I think
actually but Rodney that was doing some
kind of choice task and and and you know
their truck they were recording from
various places and trying to decode just
the way you're doing it and in addition
to the recording they also had a video
of the mouse and they used variables
from you know the the position of the
legs and so forth and it turns out that
there there was actually a lot of
information from the video just exactly
described it which is that there is a
highly correlated body movement before
attack to the right right and so
obviously has to be represented to the
brain which means that there's some
other background information there that
this is part of the whole representation
right that's quite actually an
absolutely agree I would say that if I
was a monkey person now I would say
that's road and stuff okay I take I take
two more question then I'm gonna move on
maybe you and you away the nor its
recorded so this is with seven movable
electrodes so they're not simultaneous
record it's a pooled data set and then
it's busy day after day after day so
it's a very highly over trained monkey
well yeah pay for based on wave form but
actually we don't have that information
we have the information another data set
and then when we do this analysis
actually we didn't see any difference
between the punitive Lee excitatory and
punitive Lee inhibitory neurons actually
look exactly the same on the population
level so that is actually not so this is
a this is actually pulled over to
monkeys just to make prettier plots but
you can also plot it monkey by monkey
and it looks surprisingly the same okay
so there's a there's an invariance
basically on the population level there
are some changes on the overall variance
etc but then but the main components
come out exactly the same so the monkeys
learn all the same tasks in some sense
so let me move on so let me just say you
know we've applied this to two more this
is one thing I wanted to say so you may
wonder you know could it be that we have
these different components because
they're just separate classes of neurons
maybe some classes care care more about
the stimulus some classes care more
about the decision and if you just look
at the way you have to the the encoding
rights the way you reconstruct the
neurons from these components and this
is a these are the distributions for the
different components then you see you
know it's always kind of like a sparse
laplacian type distribution which means
on the single neuron level it's really a
mixture of these components okay it's a
random mixture of each component that's
the way this thing on your own level
looks and that's why the single neuron
level looks so complicated now this is
just to flash up you know we've applied
this to many tasks and one of the nice
things is that in these different tasks
you basically always get a snapshot of
what's happening in the population level
so you don't have to look at the single
cells okay but to summarize this
basically what we've seen is that at the
population level simple linear readouts
allow us to demux
things that look quite complicated on
the single cell level okay you these
complicated task dependencies on a
single cell level and kind of disappear
if you look at the population level just
using a simple linear readout so the
next thing I wanted to talk about is
moving from yeah so so you you did this
this method basically on the PST HS once
you train to you train this can you use
this to do actually a single trial
readout or I mean it does this help you
to tell anybody no it's in poverty if
you use now this decoder so if you had
simultaneous recording so you're on
alright because this is not
simultaneously
so the reason we use PSD age is
precisely because it's not simultaneous
in fact if you have simultaneous
recordings then you should use the
method on the simultaneous recordings
and so what I want to talk about next is
basically moving up from one population
to two populations and this is work that
was mostly done by a grad student that I
share with Byron you actually barney
from Carnegie Mellon actual summate oh
so he's the one who did all the analysis
and it's on data from Adam cones lab
collected by I mean San Joaquin and the
question is the following
the question is basely okay let's assume
we had simultaneous recordings from two
areas what do we think about the way
they communicate so on the theory side I
would say the the simplest thing the
simplest way of which you can think
about error communication would really
just be a standard feed-forward network
the way Italians described this morning
and in a standard feed-forward Network
basically everything is communicated
unless of course you compress the
information then there is information us
to compute through compression but one
of the things we we sort of know about
the brain is that you know it seems that
not always everything is communicated so
there is a there is something like
sometimes called the bitter routing
problem and actually Bruno had some nice
work on this in the 90s and then your
question is how do you select
information that you communicate to a
downstream areas what if you don't just
want to communicate everything all the
time what if you say there's a context
now I want to communicate say the visual
information and now I want to
communicate the auditory information but
I don't always want to have everything
in an high or the area okay so then I
think a more classical way of thinking
about this how to change what you
communicate from one area to another is
basically to change the connectivity of
the two areas that seems like the most
straightforward way of doing it and one
way of doing that and I hope I don't
misrepresent you Bruno it's basically
that you that you do it through control
units the results of what crystallized
Mis actually uses in this sort of
elaborate model of the whole human brain
use control units that nonlinear modify
basically what you're going to
communicate on the experimental side
there isn't actually a very much work on
inter area communication because the
technology hasn't existed so there's
work on the neuron to neuron level when
people record to neurons in two
different areas and then we could look
at cross correlations there's a lot of
work about lfts where the LSP is
basically the local field potential so
it's a summary signal that you extract
from a whole bunch of neurons in one
area and there's also a lot of work on
recording elf peas in different areas
and people that have studied that
usually say you know the Weig areas
communicate is through synchronization
they may synchronize oscillations within
the two areas and then spikes kind of
write transmitted under on the peaks of
these oscillations so there's a theory
called communication so coherence or
some ideas basically that say how area
to area communication is supposed to
work so what we set out to do is very
look at two populations and see what can
we learn from that if we have population
recordings in two areas and the areas
that we used is basically v1 so there
are simultaneous recordings with the
Utah array from the output layers of v1
and then with tetrode from the input
layers of me too so that's shown here in
a marker
so you have a Utah are a that basically
records in b1 and then there Tet roads
that basically pierced through the
cortex to reach areas in b2 and one of
the nice things about using b1 and b2 is
that you have retinal to pee so you can
kind of make sure that the two areas
recording actually are communicating
because you know just because the two
areas doesn't actually mean that all the
neurons are communicating with all the
neurons but with retina 2p you have good
chances of saying okay maybe those
neurons are actually communicating and
that's kind of shown here so here you
have these blue dots neurons in v1 shown
basically in the visual field and the
centers are the Centers of the receptive
fields the receptive fields generally
have the type of size that shown by this
blue circle here and then the red
neurons neurons recorded in b2 using
these tetra recordings and the red
circle shows you the size of the
receptive field in v2 yes what is it
you're recording
what are we recording with the territory
no no we're recording the input layers
of b2 that's the key idea basically so
you should record in my opinion so much
as the tips of the petrol sir yes
exactly yes and I'm too taught to show
evidence that this actually worked so I
don't have the I don't of the slides on
this because it's actually the work from
bottom cones lab but what they did is
just do cross correlations between
neurons and pairwise recorded and you
see that Sarah that makes me have a nice
two millisecond peak so I mean I always
find this surprising you know you pick
in your sub sample heavily from these
populations you take two of these
electrodes and you see well that looks
like a direct connection you know it's
just a two millisecond delay you see a
peak that says you know we tune your
unfired exactly two minutes second after
b1 you're on
so basically the advantage here is that
you know v2 is actually the major target
for v1 output because of topic maps to
kind of align your recordings to a
certain extent so yet the way we're
going to analyze the data so we're going
to basically take a population vector
and in this case we're going to quantify
it as a spy count and I'll be happy to
explain later why you know we don't use
the more a finer resolution in time so
to be 100 millisecond spike out and then
we go through basically a stimulation
period here so there's a one-second
stimulation where this grating is shown
okay and if you do that and you do it
over many many many trials then what you
get is a lot of variability in the
response of the v1 population and that
variability is barely shown here so if
you this dot space is 100 millisecond
time window either by sliding it through
constant stimulation but also by going
over many trials I think on average to
like 200 300 trials and one of the
experiments its anesthetized monkey its
dot is in some sense we could call it a
trial but actually a single stimulus
presentation is one second and a dot E
is one a milliseconds so every 10 dots
per trial if you want your from so one
way we think about this data is in the
following we say okay what we're looking
here is there is a mean operating point
okay a mean activity and we have
fluctuations around that mean activity
and we're going to say like these
fluctuations on the population level
they aren't super super huge okay so
when I think of these fluctuations as a
way of exploring how changes in v1
activity are going to affect v2 activity
so let's just think about it for a
second so one thing we see here is
really there is a there's a dominant
dimension along which the v1 activity
fluctuates and that this one so I put
down a dominant dimension here but it's
really you can think about this at the
time of manifold that we had earlier the
manifold of activity you know the
manifold on which the activity in v1
lies okay I'm just going to call it
dominant dimension or dominant
dimensions
so where the we on activity moves around
but now let's think about v2 so what
does V 2 add let's just think about a
single neuron in V 2 so what we can do
is we can color-code
the V 2 the activity of that single
neuron for each of these V 1 population
activities so this is a schematic here
but basically what it's supposed to
illustrate is you know when the V 1
activity was over here the neuron was
not firing and as you move in this
direction the V 2 neuron starts firing a
lot okay so that gives rise to the idea
of a predictive dimension so this is the
dimension in the v1 activity that when
activity changes in that direction the
activity of a v2 neuron is affected okay
and so in some sense I would say it's
because the stimulus is a static
stimulus is totally true that eventually
you would want to go to like time
wearing activity so I would say at this
point we're just making our lives easier
yeah that's the main reason so the one
thing I want to illustrate this way is
that well first of all I want to say
predictive dimensions to quit phones and
just think about you get them by using
linear regression okay if you do a
linear regression here then what this
direction illustrates are the regression
coefficients that you would use if you
were to try to predict a v2 neuron from
the activity of the v1 population that's
what this is supposed to illustrate but
what should be clear is that a priori
there's no reason that the dominant
dimensions on which Paisley activity
changes in this manifold in v2 has
anything to do with the dimensions by
which you can predict activity in v2
okay a priori this may be different
so let's think about predicting the v-2
population not just a signal between
Iran so here I show you one you're on
you can imagine that you know another
neuron may take up the one activity in a
different direction so we call that a
different predictive dimension and then
you can sort of add all the neurons in
v2 okay and what you basically see is is
that you know for each neuron you get a
different direction but now you may
wonder do all these directions truly
span the full v1 activity space so
everything that is happening in v1 being
communicated to v2 or could it be that
the predictive dimensions span a
subspace so could it be that you see the
v1 neurons actually like the v2 neurons
only respond to activity that changes in
a particular manifold in v1 that may not
be the dominant manifold okay so that's
what we set out to test and so to
include some terminology we're going to
call this the communication subspace in
the sense that we say this is the v1
activity that fluctuates on this
manifold is being communicated to OB to
where as activity and we want that
fluctuates orthogonal e to that manifold
will not be communicated to v2 so we're
going to call that private let me say
there could be private activity in v1
that b2 never sees and then there's
activity that be to sees we're going to
call that communicated activity of
communication subspace now one thing
that you may wonder about you know
that's all kind of cool but is there
really anything special between
communication between two areas so to
figure that out just a second we we
introduced the control we said let's
actually see whether whatever you find
whether it has any kind of relevance and
so we decided to basically take a subset
of the v1 neurons of the recorded v1
neurons that is matched in size and
firing a distribution to these vitor
neurons we call it a holdout okay that
we extracted from the source v1
population and we call that target v1
and that will be our control because we
want to see whether there's anything
special about b---one b---two
communication so we put up this
arbitrary subset of target v1 neurons
that will tell us whether inter intra
area communication is actually any
different from inter area communication
so in the previous slide the cartoon
slide how the downstream region in this
case v2 will also be in some state and
it's States contextual state if you will
will determine what it can or cannot
listen to so how should or whatever
should should not pay attention to show
how should I think about that component
of this problem with respect to the
hypothesis you laid out here so I guess
the the hypothesis we have in some sense
if every 2 X like a readout on v1 and
the readout itself we're going to keep
that constant so we don't assume that
you know if you two can twist around
it's read out so that's the underlying
assumption and if you take that
assumption then that problem that you
just described doesn't really arrive
arise but we can talk about it later
well that makes sense or not yeah that
makes everything a lot more complicated
that is totally true because you're
right you know eventually there'll be
feedback so we think of this as a
feed-forward system so one one reason to
do that is really because the
feed-forward connects so we have the the
output of p1 and the input of it - these
are the layers that we record the
feedback though goes through a different
layer so there'll be a little bit it's
not as direct let's put it this way but
it'll also come along so there's some
other work we did actually just sort of
try to disentangle the feed-forward in
the feedback a little bit but over the
slide I can show those slides later is
and what you see actually is there that
the feed-forward really arises at the
beginning of the stimulus with a two
millisecond delay and then at the end of
the stimulus so like after half a second
you see a 20 much more sluggish with a
20 millisecond delay type of feedback
arising and you can figure that out by
very look
at cross-correlations not between
neurons but within populations using
canonical correlation analysis when very
fine time bands and then you actually
see there's a feedback component it's
not as strong as the feed-forward
component but it exists but for this I'm
just going to ignore it now okay
okay so we have this control the target
v1 and here are the results so let's
start first with just predicting all the
two neurons from the v1 activity just
using linear regression so use the full
linear regression model and it's
properly regularized etc I'm showing the
test performance and you see that
basically on average you can explain
something like in this case 13.5 percent
of the variance of v2 from the V one
population so the first question you may
ask is like thirteen five percent of the
variance that does not seem like a lot
okay
it turns out though that we have to
think again you know we have like
roughly 100 v1 Iran's here we have 25 b2
neurons these populations are heavily
subsist assume subsampling so you build
a simple linear model with subs and then
your sub sample from it and to linear
regression then this performance is
actually surprisingly consistent with
that the performance also surprisingly
consistent was just assuming you have
100 v1 neurons 25 v2 neurons but they're
not linearly coupled they're linear
process or models so you put a Poisson
process afterwards also degenerates your
performance a lot so I'm actually
initially I was like well you know with
digging around the noise but now I'm
very convinced this actually is actually
surprisingly high in some sense for disp
linear regression okay so this is the
full linear regression model now as I
said we wanted to ask but I actually we
to really reach out everything from v1
or it only reads out a subspace so to
test that we're going to go back again
to reduce drank regression which is
regression under a rank constraint and
one way to understand this rank
constrain is to say well it actually
introduces something like this
communication subspace
okay well be one activity gets first
compressed it on to this manifold that
is the predictive or communicative
manifold which then gets expanded to
explain v2 activity if you use this
rooster egg regression model and you
change the number of predictive
dimensions that show here then you see
that well you know this is just if you
have one predictive dimension this is if
you have to predict of the manuals and
essentially after to predictive
dimensions you're already as good as the
full regression
model so in this particular example the
answer is essentially that how many of
you won your demands do you need to
explain v2 what you just need two
dimensions okay so it does indeed look
quite flat now this is just one session
in in one monkey so you can basically
pull across data oh no first we look at
the v1 to v1 interaction and that one is
very just different and that's the
interesting bit so here we're just
trying to predict me1 neurons from v1
neurons again that's the four model very
similar to what we had here in terms of
the overall possibility to predict
things but then you see now as you
include more and more predictive
dimensions it actually rises much slower
and in this case you need what is it
six creative dimensions to be able to
explain v1 activity from the one
activity okay so it's not as low
dimensional as we want to v2 so there's
a distinct difference this basically
shows the whole data set so here we have
the number of predictive dimensions in
target B 1 this is the number of
predictive dimensions in v2 and you
generally see we always need more demand
to predict Li one activity then we need
to predict v2 activity okay that's a
general outcome stimulus so we have a
pretty good idea of was most features
that we when you're as responsible and
we have some sense of future
you responsible so if I design a
stimulus such that the activates v1
neurons a lot and it does not activate
d2 neurons things like this analysis to
say the communication subspaces is zero
there's no communication subspace
whereas if I change the steam of space
that activate we will be two different
different answers use alright so that is
that is an interesting question so again
to to emphasize this is for a single
stimulus okay and the changes with C and
B one activity they're really just
shared fluctuations in v1 for a constant
stimulus so the question is so they're
two questions one it's like why are
their shared fluctuations in v1 at all
if the stimulus is always the same you
know and we can talk about that over
lunch everyone has their own ideas but
you see these share fluctuations then
the other question is what actually
happens if you change the stimulus okay
because you could say oh let's instead
of just looking at these shared
fluctuations on how they are being
transmitted to v2 let's actually
manipulate the stimulus and see how that
changes lead to activity that's a much
more complicated question actually
because stimulus space is so big
let's just say we try to explore atom
corn is actually trying to explore that
experimentally now but we haven't
analyzed the data yet but it's a far
more complicated question the question
I'm trying to answer here which is
leadeth fixed stimulus only the try to
try variability shared fluctuation to
me--one and how are they being
transmitted to be two ways the the
result here is that if you want to
predict b1 activity from b1 activity you
need a lot more dimensions than if you
want to predict b2 activity so one
possible confound here could be that you
know maybe just to be 2 activity itself
is just lower dimensional and that
surprisingly turns out to be not the
case exactly the opposite happens
there'll be two activity is actually
much higher dimensional so let me
explain what I just said so I said you
know we find that there are less
dimensions we need to predict me too but
what if the manifold on which the v2
activity lives is actually only
two-dimensional now we kind of trivial
that you only need 2 dimensions right
because there isn't anything else to
predict turns out that's not the case
though the manifold on which the v2
activity lives is X
be higher than the manifold on which the
v1 activity lives okay so there's more
stuff going on in v2 that we cannot
predict with our source v1 population we
only predict a lower dimensional
manifold in v2 so the 2 is higher
dimension than v1 it could be that v2
space is more curved so generally it's
true so generally the assumption again
we make is that while it's likely that
the interaction between the 1 and v2 is
non-linear by focusing on a similar
image single stimulus and just the
shared fluctuations it's kind of like a
linear approximation on to maybe some
kind of nonlinear function but you're
right if that non error function is far
too curved ok then we're in in trouble
so it's based on the assumption that you
know these share fluctuations can be
well described by a linear model so if
we know basically look at the at the
dimensionality of the population that
versus how much dimensions you need to
predict them then here's the result for
v1 so this is the dimensionality of the
v1 of the target v1 population and
that's how many dimensions we need to
predict it and the interesting thing is
even though these were estimated by
different methods so there's factor
analysis to measure how many dimensions
there are a population and then reduced
or aggression to measure how many we
need to predict the population you see
that in v1 from v1 to v1 this lies
nicely on a diagonal to on a diagonal so
you need as many predictive dimension as
there are dimensions in that activity to
predict it the closed circles there's
those of the means of five different
sessions so basically what each of these
circles is is one stimulus okay and then
there there are five different sessions
and there eight stimuli for each session
so they're all together 40 points
if you do the same thing with B 1 with
respect to B 2 then you'll find that in
fact a number of dimensions that you
need to predict the V 2 activity is much
lower than the number of dimensions that
the V 2 activity basically has okay so
that just summarizes those two results
there's several controls which are not
going to go to in detail but you may
wonder about you know is this trivial in
some sense or is it not trivial
so we claim it's not trivial so it
cannot be explained by you know maybe
they actually only a few of you two
neurons that even can be predicted in
the first place and that's why you see
this that's not the case it's actually
really a population effect maybe this is
just trivial because if you assume that
the connectivity is not full but like
there's sparse connectivity there's a
physical bottleneck or there's something
in the connectivity maybe that's a way
of explaining this but it turns out that
doesn't give you the results you could
think maybe it's nonlinearities
basically what Sophie said so again we
can only test that models so what we did
is we did a simple complex cell model so
assume there's a quadratic non-linearity
in v2 so you have linear quadratic
non-linearity so that also doesn't give
you the result you can think maybe it's
a subsampling effect so you can build a
big v1 v2 network you subsample again
you don't see this result then another
thing that you may want to ask this one
how do these predictive dimensions
actually align with the dominant
dimensions because so far I've only told
you one is bigger than the other but I
haven't said anything about how they
align and that's what I had initially
you know maybe the dimensions that
predict v2 are different from the
dimensions of the v1 activity or maybe
not and it turns out they are different
so here's the way of testing that so
this is Paisley we include more and more
dimensions to predict the two activity
that's the predictive performance of v2
this is if you use the predictive
dimension so the the ideal dimensions
that you should use to predict me - so
here you know in a 3d subspace basically
and that's all you need for this
particular example to predict me - but
you can also say let's try the dominant
dimensions and we want the dominant
subspace and we want to predict Li - if
you do that the
this is the craft you get so you start
with a with a with the dimension in v1
along which the activity changes the
most okay then the the 2d subspace along
which activity changes the most and you
see it actually eventually rises to the
same performance but even after 10
dimensions you're not entirely there so
tells you that these predictive
dimensions actually are not the dominant
modes of v1 activity on the other hand
if you do a v1 v1 study then you see
that the predictive dimensions are the
dominant dimensions okay so that's the
key difference so how do we summarize
this so here's a simple way of
summarizing this graphically so imagine
this is the source v1 activity the
population activity kind of show like as
a set and the dark colors show you
population activities that occur more
often if you want okay
activity patterns that occur more often
then barely what I've shown you is that
the subset of the one activity that
actually predicts B - nice tilted away
from these dominant v1 modes okay and
it's low dimensional so there's a
smaller subset of the one activity that
allows you to predict me - it's it's
lower dimensional and it's tilted away
from these dominant dimensions on the
other hand v1 v1 intra area
communication is a bit like this it
actually relies on the dominant patterns
of activity in v1 to be able to predict
another subset of neurons and we want so
that's the main difference of v1 v2
communication so where were the neurons
what layer in v1 did you say my anatomy
is - I always forget at the output layer
what is the output layer so 3 5 6 but
you're missing a major input -
therefore v2 from big one that comes
shortly or five would be one yeah I
wonder - I don't have an answer we can
we are be interested to hear about that
afterwards okay that is certainly too so
one thing you have to remember is that
b2 activity is so in some sense this
schematic is a bit wrong because I'm
showing you that we predict all of you
to activity but we don't there's a lot
of activity in b2 that we're not
predicting from v1 there could be the
other input so there are there are other
inputs to b1 a2 b2 here are you're
asking me too many questions did you say
that you looked at different subsets of
v1 because it could be that some of the
ones that you record from didn't
actually go to each other so we check
for the respective oh I see what you're
saying so we don't have the anatomy
right but it turns out actually in this
study but also in many other study it's
maybe less of a problem because of all
the core variability that you have
between populations so even though not
many of these cells may actually project
to v2 they may be cells that co-vary
with cells that do projective it - and
that's why you can do this type of
analysis in the first place maybe you're
going to get here but yeah I will either
these can be private dimensions
that aren't transmitted or I know
looking at the data I would I would call
what's going on
abstracting away the the private
dimensions and it doesn't need the the
extra dimension that me to don't need to
come from elsewhere they can be
constructed by v2 you know is also
talking yeah there's also the satisfy
HIV one creates orientation v2 will
create something from dimensions the
information it isn't v1 but their
consolation in creates new dimensions so
it cannot it cannot really expand on the
information that it gets from u1 unless
it has other inputs of course but it
could transform them and complicated
nonlinear ways because if there were
linear ways we would capture them but if
there are transformations that are more
complicated than we would potentially
not capture them with layer more trans
non-linearity can be just thresholds and
boring things the combinations can be
linear and and you can talk about it but
yes yes yes so let me just briefly state
so what could is actually being good for
me okay and that brings me why actually
are we analyzing data at all like a bit
a little bit of a philosopher thing
philosophical thing so for me what data
analysis is supposed to be first Moss is
like a way of looking at the data it
actually gives you ideas for how to
construct your theories something like
data and now this is gonna bring us all
the way to understand the brain I would
say it's a way of making a connection to
theories alright you could say well I
have my theory and you know with the
theory I can break every single spike
let's just say there will be beautiful
but we're not quite there yet so we want
to find an interface between the way we
think about theories and the actual data
and so that's the way I think about data
analysis you compare your psychoanalysis
data analysis - psychoanalysis but you
can say maybe there's nothing wrong with
a because I'm saying like there's
nothing wrong with the day that we're
saying it doesn't actually need to be
analyzed by the data is correct the
reason we analyze it because we want to
look at it in different ways okay so
here's a way of understanding why
something like this could be useful so
imagine we had a source area and it has
two target target area a target area B
one possibility is that the way the
arrows communicate is in such a way you
have like these means each of these
lines is now when you're on in one of
these target areas and they scan the
activity space of the view of the sort
area in this way so the green neurons
and the red neurons and now if this
happens and you start varying the
activity in the source area then what's
going to happen is both target areas
they're going to see what happens in the
source area okay so there's in some
sense everyone sees everything on the
other hand if you have these
communication subspaces and the
communication subspaces are different
for different downstream areas so let's
say you know the way the connectivity
from Eric from the source area to the
downstream area being set up is such
that it reads out this bit of activity
in the source space and the way
connectivity to area a is set up so that
you read out activity in this manifold
of the source base then actually you can
route information okay you I mean you
you you move the problem of course in
this in this case you move the problem
to the source area you say it's the
problem of the source area to make sure
that the proper things are being
communicated so in this case if the
source area now varies in such a way
that basic thing actually this is - this
is the okay no it's sorry I gotta like
don't see the great thing here so I'm
going to put my laser pointer may be
wrong so this variation is orthogonal to
this gray box here okay which you should
see I have a hard time seeing it which
is the
which is the subspace of the downstream
area be okay
and since it's a thar go to that
subspace it's private for area B and
area B doesn't see anything but this
variation still projects onto the
communication subspace of area a so area
a sees something and alternatively if
the activity now varies orthogonal to
area a then area B will see something in
area a will see nothing okay so it's one
way of routing information between areas
that doesn't put the problem on the
connectivity it just puts the problem on
the area that wants to send information
to a different downstream targets so
it's not like the problem is soft
we just shifted it okay in my last five
minutes I want to just give a brief
teaser actually so to summarize this
understanding in telecommunication by
adjusting population activities nina
raedo it's allowed to route information
of different downstream targets that's
sort of the idea so on all of these
methods I've basically shown you how to
use linear readouts this is a teaser
because you guys have so feet in here
for like I think two months and I
thought you had given a talk already but
maybe you will give a talk and then the
teaser can be fulfilled but it's work
I've waited it together with Sophie and
many other people which I was unable to
put on the slide before it is this
morning hmm anyways so let's start with
this a linear readout again so the
linear readout is actually that's
something that's started with the spikes
and all of the stuff I've shown you I
kind of mysteriously left out the spikes
because I always started with the firing
rates so we did the filtering we used
the firing rates and then we have these
linear ways of basically combining them
to find some kind of linear readouts
okay so but let's bring the spikes back
into the picture so one thing you may
wonder about if we really think this is
how it works in the brain you can think
as a linear readout as as a
digital-to-analog conversion you have
these digital signals that are spikes
binary signals you put them through the
readout and it gives you a bunch of
analog readouts a bunch of analog
variables so one thing you may wonder
about is how do you invert that
transformation how do you go how does
the brain go from these analog signals
to these digital signals now obviously
that is not something that the brain
necessarily has to do okay I guess you
could imagine that there is never
explicitly done but I'm going to
advertise the idea that it may be useful
to think about it okay how would you do
that how would you go from these analog
signals to these spike trains so I think
the first person that actually has done
that is crystallized myth and one thing
I want to emphasize is this can actually
not be linear okay so that so for those
of you who paid a lot of attention you
notice that secretly we always assume
that everything is linear in these
methods but you cannot go linearly back
to the spike trains there are basically
two reasons
one reason is you know because they're
spikes what do you say maybe I don't
care the other reason is because firing
rates actually are quantities that are
constrained to be positive and in all of
the methods we use that actually never
appeared okay so this transformation
from some analog signal to a spike train
it has to be nonlinear so as I said the
first one who basic did this is
crystallized myth and Charlie Anderson
they developed this neural engineering
framework and one way of thinking about
what they do in this context would be
the following find a nonlinear
transformation from these analog signals
to the firing rate and then transform
every single firing rate into a spike
train using something like a spiking
neural model okay the disadvantage of
that so this procedure works the
disadvantage of this procedure from the
point of view of neuroscience is since
you couldn't take these analog signals
and transform them one by one into spike
trains all the spike trains turn out to
be irregular okay there are regular
firing and that's not what we see in the
brain so at some level that can't be how
it works
so another way of thinking about how it
works is to make the following two
assumptions you say okay what we
actually want to do is we want to bound
the error so when we go back from these
analog signals to these spike trains and
then we think about how we're going to
read out those spike trains to get back
to the analog signal there will be an
error there will be an error because
discritization step in with we okay
that's the minimum area are going to
make just because it discretize it into
spikes so you can say let's assume that
that you want to bound the error and
let's assume that you want to be
efficient with respect to some objective
function so efficiency sometimes I think
sounds a bit strong I would just
actually by now rather say let's bound
the error but not be totally dumb about
it okay
so that way a phrase efficiency and if
you do that and that's my teaser then
there are three very interesting
consequences that you get just from this
principle linear readout you bound the
error and you want to be efficient you
get that you're on should be coupled by
electron emission you get that
individual neurons are balanced in the
exact or inhibitory input which in turn
gives you irregular and unreliable spike
trains and you get surprisingly that
these networks are robust they're robust
they have instantaneous robustness
against the loss of neurons against
synaptic miss tuning against noise etc
so that's my teaser if you find it
unsatisfying that's because it's a
teaser but as I said you have Sofie here
and she can give you all the details
so to summarize that this movement
little advertisement for linear readouts
I think for me they are very invariant I
have not seen any reasons to change to
go away from them so I would claim
that's how it works that's it
thanks for listening so in the teaser is
this the problem
haven't you created this problem with
trying to predict what the spikes were
to give rise to this analog signal is
that something the brain ever worries
about or does is that as the brain
concerned about this that's a much more
complicated question let's say you can
so I think actually it may be concerned
about it there's a that's a very
beautiful paper from without a peshkov
engineer I think at MIT I think he only
wrote one paper in neuroscience from
98mm and so he makes the following
comparison she compares brains to
digital computers and he says in digital
like if you take
digital computer and you scale it up and
think let's make it as big that it can
compute with as many bits per second as
the brain you have to make a
back-of-the-envelope calculation for
that and then you say how much energy
with the digital computer use and I
think it comes up with something that
would be like a nuclear power station
that you need to power the digital
computer now the brain uses supposedly
only 12 Watts so there's like $10 of
magnitude this whole thing is off and so
the question is why is it off by so many
orders of magnitude and so he said ok
ideally if you want to be energy
efficient you should use analog
computation because you can use physics
to compute ok that's what you want to do
but then everyone that has Betty tried
to build units ID chips etc was purely
analog always runs into the problem that
you know noise builds up so pure analog
computation doesn't work either so what
what he basically suggested is maybe
what the brain does is bad idea analog
digital hybrid when you use analog
signals to compute say on the dendrites
and then you use a discretization step
so that you eliminate the noise and you
also make sure that things when they
travel over large distances don't
accumulate noise and if you think about
the architecture like that then you
actually do want to compute with the
analog signals and you do want to not
just have a transform from digital to
analog you also want to have the inverse
transform excuse me that's a very that's
a very interesting question that be
actually curious to talk because I think
that the framework that advertised but
never explained in some sense shares
some similarities with the higher-order
Sigma Delta modular moderniser so if you
know something about them actually be
curious to talk there are papers and
suggest that for the neuron
exactly but we do it on the population
level right that's the important thing
it's not a neuron by neuron type it's on
your own brain
it's a population level thing so coming
back to your v1 v2 analysis how do you
roll out the firing of a bias
simulations so like to rule out things
we cannot use them we cut we have the
data doesn't what is a sprite so what we
do is we basically set up a model for
every one a bunch of neurons for v1
instead of a bunch of neurons for v2 we
decide on the wiring diagram and then we
run our analysis on that model and then
if we see you know that model doesn't
spit out the same results then it's
being ruled out well of course it could
say model space is infinite dimensional
so I would say the way we think about
models we say okay what would be the
model that people would say that seems
like a reasonable model probably one be
two interactions because they check too
many other regions right so it's
unlikely that every neuron you recall
from in v1 4 checks to be 2 that's 2 but
it doesn't have to be because see the
thing is that the v1 activity is also
not that high dimensional it's like it's
like 6 7 8 dimensional and so you have
all this core variability of neurons in
v1 so even if only a few of them project
to v2
it doesn't actually change very much
even if all of them put projective it -
it does really change because you have
this constraint activity space and we
want to start out with well that's why
you don't need full wiring if if the one
activity space was barely going at all
in full dimensionality then a wiring
diagram would actually provide a bottom
a little bit with kind of yeah of course
they're compatible with with wiring
diagrams I'm just saying the wiring
diagram itself doesn't explain it that's
all
that would be beautiful so we're trying
to figure it out actually the problem
with figuring out this so just to back
up what the question is about so we see
these fluctuations in v1 okay so you may
wonder why are these fluctuations of you
want and I would say in the field that
kind of two alternative explanations so
one is this is just feed-forward noise
the reason the one fluctuates round is
because you know the processing from the
retina to v1 may be noisy or even the
stimulus may not always be exactly the
same location on the retina which it
won't you know because they're micro
saccades and whatnot and that is the
fluctuations that we see in the v1
population activity an alternative
explanation is that these fluctuations
are generated internally in v1 okay
because of the way v1 is being wired so
things so these question is basically
can we see whether this stimulus
subspace moves in the same manifold as
the fluctuations we see or whether it's
orthogonal to those fluctuations and the
same period question is not easy to
answer but I mean we I'd say we're
moving in that direction
one last question these are the
dimension is extremely exciting so is
there a paper about that which sees us
these are not the teaser yes there's a
there there are papers about that and
that's also like I mean I'm leaving on
Friday but Sophia thing is here for
another month so she can give a talk
about it so this is a review paper we
wrote in a junior science about the
papers that underlie this teaser all
right thanks a lot
[Applause]